oh snap
we live hot breath verse welcome back to
hot breath the show where you learn
comedy from the pros i'm your host
comedian joel byers today's guest
shares the spirit we do here at hot
breath of comics helping comics of that
positive supportive environment crushing
out the negative and competitive aspect
of comedy he's the ceo of big laugh
comedy we're doing this live on our
youtube channel so if you're not
subscribed there yet go subscribe to our
youtube channel where we do q and a's
every single week
but without further ado ladies and
gentlemen welcome comedian and ceo
of big laugh comedy the one and only
brandon lewin everyone give it up for
brandon
what's up everybody what's up joel thank
you so much for having me on woo yeah
we out here
i am not a comedian by the way i did it
for a year and a half and then i just i
called it quits
oh literally right before we went on
you're like when i started comedy five
years ago yeah yeah i started doing it
and then quickly realized that that just
wasn't my thing so um i i love comedy i
love stand up but
the the reason i actually stopped was
just because i have kids and a family
and a time i was a little bit later in
life and
um i also just not built for doing the
same thing over and over and over again
which is obviously a big part of comedy
and that's something i quickly realized
when i first started doing it was like i
remember i just didn't know enough and i
i was saying this before we jumped on
which kind of led us into the oh um
am i allowed to swear on this by the way
yeah let her rip fam all right yeah yeah
i have a bit of a potty mouth but i look
like a mormon but it's all right
i know you you do that's why i asked
where you were at i thought you were in
utah
um
[Laughter]
but i um yeah so when i when i first
started doing it i remember i would go
to open mics and there was there were
people on there and they were doing the
same bits over and over and over again
and i was like why the are they
doing that and then i quickly realized
what it was they were just working out
the kinks and
um and it's part of the process and i
just like my brain
does not go there like even when i i
used to teach
like courses for marketers and even when
i did that although
um i had to use the script i would
switch it up every so often because it
just it rep repetition was is just not
my thing
like i i get the the core aspect of it
and then like kind of branching off but
um i don't know so anyway i i have a i
love comedy i love comedians but i found
my place and my kind of lane uh which
was comedy production man that's that's
my bread and butter i was i was
raised in marketing and sales and so now
i just get to apply that for comedians
and help them from a business
perspective too because i quickly
realized that comedians
are not the best business people and um
yes and so i would see and and marketers
either so i would see a lot of them uh
promoting to the comedy group on
facebook about their show when it's all
comedians in that group when they really
should be promoting to the people who
would be coming and buying tickets and
watching them and so
that's where i saw an opportunity to
come in and help them
and do that and so far so good
yeah you came from like used to like
train like corporate trainings for
companies and stuff right that these
used to like do this at a high level
yeah my uh right so i i actually um i've
been an entrepreneur since i came out of
college uh really and
i took a i took what i call a three-year
hiatus from that and i worked for a
couple agencies and the last agency i
worked for
was a digital marketing agency that
specialized in
both training and consulting on google
analytics and
digital advertisements and so we had
clients that were
you know fortune 500 companies
from universities to franchises to
toyota i trained uh the digital marketer
from interscope records at one point so
a lot of different larger
organizations that came through there
but they had two sides they had the
actual like consulting business and then
they have the training business and the
training business is what i came on to
do and they were looking for what they
called a unicorn which was someone who
had the understanding and know how how
to market something but also had the
people people skills to go out and
actually train and do these trainings
and so i was in charge of doing that and
we grew the business about eight hundred
thousand dollars in the first uh eight
uh increased by eight hundred thousand
dollars in the first eight months that i
was on there and then i was out there
training so i would go i was out like
every other week um spending sometimes
four or five days out on the road just
doing these trainings in front of you
know groups that range anywhere from 15
people to 200 people so it was a lot of
fun man it uh it was one thing that i
there was a goal of mine to do some
business traveling which i did i went
you know all over north america
including
um canada and spent some time up in
vancouver and calgary which calgary is
beautiful it's also something i didn't
know about him that that's the
texas part of canada
cowboys and catmull up there and
barbecue there's a lot of
yeah i didn't know that i walked in
there i was like where the am i
like
my houston because there was like
everybody was wearing cowboy hats and
cowboy boots and
it was everything was meat and and oil
but apparently it's a big oil um
i guess territory so
uh so yeah it was it was it's it was
kind of an interesting background it was
fun but i i believe everything led me to
to this point
what are some like based on your like
even like your marketing expertise like
what are some big
tips you could have you see comics
always making mistakes you know and here
on hot breath we love helping and
educating comics but you know that's
something even me
i'm you know as a comedian 12 years in
i'm like well how how can i market
myself better or like you know what are
what are some kind of
big takeaways or things that you see a
lot of mistakes you see comics making or
just tips for us really
so two things i think one
you should own your own assets and what
i mean by that is
instead of relying on social media
although it is a big part of marketing
especially nowadays and that's where all
the masses are but
if you and i've always been um
this has been this has been my
philosophy for for years probably like
10 plus years now is that social media
is a really it's a necessary evil um
but as we've seen because i've seen it
firsthand i'm sure you and plenty of
other people who are watching this have
seen it too is that we are um
essentially
uh we're victims to social media
whatever they wake up and decide to do
they can do and we have no control over
that so we've seen comedians get i've
seen personally get big comedians get
shadow banned um you know tim tim dillon
is no longer on instagram because he got
shadow band and he can't promote on on
there really anymore and so and maybe he
does i actually haven't really checked
in a while but i the last time i heard
he was like i'm not doing this
anymore um but
the people have gotten shadow band and
it's really affected their ticket sales
tremendously and so it's things like
that you know facebook started doing
that way back in the day when facebook
first started i remember i was on there
they would um
you would spend it was so easy you would
spend time building up your business
page and getting people on there and
then one day they woke up and they said
we're changing the algorithm now you
have to earn this
and they changed it up and you went from
being able to see all the followers that
you had on there if you spent time
building up a hundred thousand followers
on there they said now on average five
percent of your followers are going to
see your post unless you pay to play or
they're extremely engaged
and it's it's really unfortunate because
people spend a lot of time building this
up and then they can do whatever they
want to do and then we have to
uh um adapt to those changes and it's
not it's not good so what i always
recommend is two things one
own your assets meaning that if you're a
traveling comedian you're going out
there
and you're selling tickets collect all
the emails clubs should give you the
emails they should give you the contact
information
shouldn't be a question um
third uh or or i should say that i don't
know if that's second or third i don't
know you're good
but uh you should also have a website i
think having a website is very important
it's not you don't need the fanciest of
websites but they're i mean for people
who are just starting off there are
templated kind of drag and drop websites
available like squarespace i always use
squarespace at kind of like a beginner's
level one and then if you can invest in
getting a little bit more um
you know in depth because the the only
problem with squarespace is that you
don't have full control of what you do
with the marketing aspect so like search
engine optimization and stuff um you
don't have full control over that where
if you go like a wordpress website you
can plug in um a yoast seo which is a is
a plug-in and you can use that and that
that helps tremendously so you can be
found uh organically and so
uh so emails website and then i i've
actually found the text messaging right
now is extremely popular uh and it's
also a very nice uh ticket seller so we
we've grown we have an email list of
about 16 000 people in in local the
local area from people have bought
tickets we've collected more but in all
honesty there's some people that
unsubscribe plus the way we sell tickets
we only really collect one person's
email address where sometimes they can
purchase up to four tickets so sometimes
we're only capturing a fourth of the
people that are coming through there but
we try to do other things to get people
to subscribe and um and enter their
information
but text messaging
we found we have a 16 000
person email list but we have a 2 000
person text message messaging list and
the 2 000 person text messaging list
actually sells
buys more tickets than the email list
does
wow
yeah so
um they're hot they know what they're
doing like we've set it up where if you
we use a tool called community
it's not an inexpensive tool but it is a
great one because you actually can
use your own number um or i shouldn't
say your own number but you can use a
real number instead of like a 614 or
whatever it is when you do those certain
text messaging services but you what you
can do is you set up a number whatever
area code you're in you get it set it up
people can text you you can build out a
little bit of like a welcome like uh
like uh funnel so you can make it sound
like you're talking to them directly
and then you can schedule and post
things and then also they give you
analytics so you so if you're a comedian
for example when you're collecting
people's text messaging you will be able
to see who's in what city
and if you want to say you got shows
coming up in chicago
you can
go on to your text messaging group and
start letting them know that like the
pre-sale starting
or you know only a couple of tickets are
left or whatever it is or just let them
know that it's on sale and you can send
it out directly to that demographic you
can also segment it by um different
population or different demographics age
groups also uh sex male female or gender
i should say
um so i gotta be careful what i say
you're canceled brandon it's over yeah
this is all a ruse to get you canceled
that's all it took oh man
brandon's running on like very few hours
of sleep right now he's up in new york
and he's he uh jumped on here to do this
with us we do appreciate it yeah yeah no
problem man yeah so if i'm a little like
foggy headed that's that's that that's
the problem here but uh um all good um
so so yeah it's it's a it's a fantastic
tool man and i think it's it's extremely
powerful and if you use it correctly it
can really help you move tickets and
grow community too the other thing with
it is that it shouldn't all be all about
selling tickets right like it's also you
can use it for like sharing content if
you've got a blog
or if you're you know putting up like
different sketches or whatever you're
doing um you've got podcasts you've got
a live going right now this would be a
great opportunity if you were had a text
messaging test text messaging list um
although i'd be interested to see how
that would translate with like a live
podcast because i don't know how many
people watch it on their phone versus
watching and then like on their tv or
the computer but it could still be like
a good reminder just to let people know
hey here we're going live we got a new
podcast
go here click here go watch the the link
so but my guess is that most people do
everything on their phones nowadays
anyway so that still would be a pretty
effective tool to use
for sure
yeah and uh rick mccarthy said am i the
only one who thinks he looks like bert's
brother so i don't know if you've gotten
that before
oh that's great dude
i don't know if that compliment or a a
uh insult but either way i'll take it
i'll take it
we did a whole campaign during uh the
pandemic where um
we called it like bird watch
and we like created a bunch of like
memes and stuff to get bird on the show
and i created a video and then um he
actually replied to the tweet and he
said yeah and then he gave me his number
and he gave me like his assistant's
number or whatnot and then that's the
last that's that's the last we've gotten
off of it
and then and then his assistant kept
like he keeps kicking the can down the
road and i was like all right fine we'll
we'll build it and they will come it was
just cool to
get his attention and him see but you
know it's
i'm not losing sleep over it
no i mean that man is is busier than
i'll hack him he's yo
tours and he just doesn't he does not
stop so for sure yeah it's all timing i
know yeah yeah 100
but um so with with big laugh like
oh and rick said that was definitely a
compliment okay yeah yeah appreciate it
because
if there's one thing bert's known for
it's his looks so that's definitely
but um let me take off my shirt too yeah
the machine uh no so um yeah i
appreciate it thanks rick
oh yeah and um yeah and uh this is a
live q and a so if uh anybody watching
live here we appreciate y'all
watching live please do share this link
on twitter or facebook or reddit
wherever you guys hang out please share
it there
and um big o actually asked he said how
do comedians become a part of your
company do they have to be in the game
for some time or does it matter
uh it's not necessarily you have to be
in the game for a certain period of time
it's
um we look at a couple different factors
and
see what what you're doing you know
sometimes we'll start with
uh
depending on the shows right like if if
if you want to get on shows it's one
thing we are pretty pretty protective of
stage time right now
um
we don't really do open mics just
because where we're located there's tons
of open mics outside of what we do
eventually we're going to have other
programs uh as far as you know getting
more stage time for younger newer
comedians but um
you know there's there's opportunities
for like podcasts like we we just
brought on a a new podcast with a young
comedian by the name of jimmy clifford
shout out to jimmy and his boys him and
greg and jj they all they put together
this great podcast they've been
doing awesome just hustling they got
like 20 or 30 episodes out already great
um it's very
illustrative um they have a lot of great
edits in it and it does a great job and
they're natural just kind of like
goofing off it's a little bro-ish but
it's it's a fantastic podcast but
he he's he's younger he's not i wouldn't
call him like he's not going to get up
there and start hosting or featuring for
any big names yet
but he does a really good job with his
podcast and i think that's one of the
easiest ways
for younger comedians i mean nowadays
everybody has a podcast but if you have
a good angle you do a good job with it
um you know like this this is a great
podcast i i was telling you before is
like i wish this was around when i first
started uh because there's nothing like
this i think really that was out there
um i would i was searching high and low
for
like how to's
how to because that's my background
right like i'm coming from a marketing
aspect and everywhere you go it's like
how do you do this how do you do that
how do you post social media and but
there was nothing like how do you write
a good joke how do you you know work out
your timing
there was there's really nothing well at
least the time when i was doing the
research there was nothing yeah um
that's why this started yeah yeah and
and having this now i mean this is this
is fantastic like um there's a local
comedian in austin well he's from l.a
originally or not originally but from um
he was out at the store and he moved
during the pandemic out there asana mod
and uh great comedian fantastic guy
um like really really good comedian he's
about to blow up and he um he started
doing this like clips where he would
break down jokes
and just like someone like a bigger
bigger comedian i think you kind of do
that too right yeah we recently started
doing stuff like that yeah
yeah so he started doing it too and it
was once i saw him posted i was like man
you got to keep doing it and
unfortunately he didn't keep doing it
but um those are one of those things
where like breaking down jokes for
people for younger comedians i think is
a really powerful tool that's something
that like we wanted to
do as far as creating some like sort of
education not necessarily like a paid
place but just like uh maybe two tools
or someone that comes in and talks a
little bit about the jokes like i
watched your clip about um the it was
like five tips from mark norman which
mark is a great dude one one of the
greatest joke writers that are out there
right now
and i was watching that that clip and
those were fantastic i mean like the
tips i was like man see maybe i would
have been a comedian if i just would
have had this around back when i first
started um
now now i'm too far down what i'm doing
that i'm like i don't i don't really
need like i always think about i was
like maybe i should get back on stage
and some people like tease me about
doing it but i'm like nah but anyway
so it goes both ways though with show
production too sometimes i'm like oh
like a few times i've been like oh maybe
i should get back into show production
and then i start back in and i was like
yo
who can help me with this like i now
co-produce a show i only do one now and
i co-produce it because i was like yo
i'm not i'm not about this life anymore
i did one for like eight years and then
like i'm like i'm good on this it's a
lot of work dude
that's the thing man it's like i've
talked to other comedians too it's like
it's it's cool to like produce one show
but
to have to like do this on a consistent
basis over and over again and try to do
your stuff it's just not worth it like
comedians this is another thing i found
from like at least from the larger more
successful comedians that are out there
the perfect the pros are going around
doing the tours
they have teams behind them they they
don't do everything themselves you know
they're not posting social media they're
not editing their clips they're not
they're not uh working out their deals
they have people doing that for them and
uh and that allows them to do what they
do best which is write jokes and perform
and i think that's
it's true in every in any kind of like
profession you know you look at
professional athletes they're not going
out there making their own deals as for
their clubs they're not going out there
figuring out their own training programs
they got people who come and do that for
them yeah and it's no different from a
comedian's standpoint i think obviously
when you're younger and you're first
starting off you have to be
a little bit more hands-on um but i
always say is like when you can get to a
point where you can find someone to help
you out in any aspect of it take
advantage of it you know find that
person um
i i used i think jimmy's a good example
too because he he found he has his buddy
greg who's kind of like his co-host he's
not really a comedian but he's just
there and he's he's good to be a part of
the conversation and he's got jj who's
his producer who um has just gone into
learning how to cut and edit and do a
really good job with it but the three of
them combined make a fantastic podcast
but i guarantee you if jimmy was trying
to do all that by himself it wouldn't be
as successful as it is now
so that that's another kind of point so
and i i don't know if i answered that
person's question about how do they get
involved with big laugh comedy
if you have a podcast or podcast idea
that's something we do take on original
content too so if you have like skits or
anything along those lines
we'll take it and help you out
if you've been performing for a little
bit longer and you're
you feel like you you've gone you've
gotten you know your legs underneath you
um we'd love to we'll take a look at
stuff i don't do clips anymore though um
people try to send me videos
and i just don't do them any more
because
i've gotten once and uh that was
the only time i needed to that that that
made me change that and um it was it's
one of those things where i actually i
got a really good clip a video from
somebody they're like oh yeah you know i
do comedy all the time i'm a writer for
this and that she sent me a clip i
watched the clip
and then i was like oh man she killed it
brought her out she was supposed to
feature for the headliner in a show now
this was before we were doing like big
big shows but um she came out and she uh
bombed horton
horribly now i mean
understandably not everyone has a great
set every single time but like when
you're supposed to be featuring for
somebody typically like i've seen enough
people feature that even if the crowd
isn't 100 in there they know how to get
them a little bit in there i mean that's
their job or at least handle it yes
exactly yeah not crumbled yeah and she
did not handle it very well yeah
that was another good story i heard a
story by uh christa stefano i think
actually was talking with um i think it
was bert or when he was on uh
uh he was on joe rogan's podcast but he
was talking about how
before he ever got up on i think it was
letterman he was going on before
letterman got off
um but he was auditioning he wanted to
get up there and his people were like
kept on coming to his shows and watching
him and watching them and he never got
the call to come on the the late show
but when he when he bombed he bombed in
front of them and he's like oh
they're not gonna want to do it and his
manager called him up was like no chris
actually they want you to come in and so
he asked him why and they said because
they saw
they saw him fail or bomb but he did it
professionally he did not crumble he
handled it like a pro and that's what
they were looking for and i think that's
another really good tip for any sort of
comedian in general is that you know
you're gonna bomb but like you gotta do
it as a pro you gotta just keep powering
through it and handle it and not crumble
and so
now on the flip side
i've i've also been burned on tapes for
in the reasons where like i didn't think
they were funny enough and then i saw
him live and they killed it
and i remember this so this my buddy
tremaine bradley uh he sent me a tape oh
when i first started producing the shows
and i watched it as i told him i sent
him a response like man i'm like you
know keep trying this is you know this
is good it's just not a good fit for me
right now or for us and for the shows
and he's like all right cool and um he i
ended up co-producing a show with
another
comedian and he knew tremaine
and he put tremaine on the show and um
tremaine went up and for about 15
minutes he killed murdered murdered the
room i was like loud as hell laughing
like cackling
um
and he got off stage and he walked up to
me and he goes he whispered in my ear he
was brandon he's like i see i told you
you should have put me up dang
fam
and that and that like the confidence
the swagger
and the fact that he did it and he
walked the walk and talked the talk i
mean that that from then on i never
questioned him
and he's been doing great man like i i
started putting up when we started doing
bigger shows i started putting him up he
got um he started featuring for steve
byrne
and then uh
and then he went on the road with him a
little bit and now he's doing some more
stuff in chicago too so right it's stuff
like that like you know
helping comedians
push their career forward is
what i love to do i love helping them
i'm not
not really looking to manage people um
the company big laugh comedy is about
here just like empowering comedians
helping them you know find opportunities
connect them with other people too you
know i i can't tell you how many times
we've connected people comedians with uh
bigger headliners who then end up taking
them out on the road or you know giving
them some spots here and there and
that's what it's all about man i mean
because at the end of the day like we're
all in this together and unfortunately
sometimes in in the community and
however you want to describe it like in
the scenes like people can be cut throat
and kind of you know i feel it too is
where like sometimes people try to come
after us for i don't know for no reason
really you know honestly but i think
that's just in life in general when
someone sees somebody on the top or
they're doing something well or positive
there's those naysayers those haters
that kind of come out and try to knock
you down so
it's just nature it's the nature of the
beast yeah i think that's what attracted
me to big laugh is like we just share
that
that spirit of just supporting comics
being positive creating a safe space
like really and just trying to give
comics opportunities wherever we can and
we're like big laugh it was
and maybe give us because um what i
reached out to you to come on here is
because you guys are currently doing
like a fundraiser
but or for lack of a better term you can
give us more specificity on it but it
was really intriguing and inspiring so
maybe give us a little context for
how big laughs started
and where it's going
sure yeah so
um i started doing comedy about six
years ago and then
about and so when i started doing it i
wanted to get in front of show in front
of a real audience
and um with my background of being an
entrepreneur
and marketing and sales
um and also being extremely impatient i
was like it i need to get in front
of it i'm like i gotta see if my
material is actually good or not and
plus i had a bunch of friends who wanted
to see it so i started producing shows
mostly to give myself more time
and and a real audience but the first
show that i booked it was like at a
brewery up where by where i live which
is like 30 minutes north of austin
and i got a hundred people to come out
and pay
on average 17 per ticket
and um only the cool thing was that only
25 of those people were like friends
that i knew everyone else from
advertisements and marketing that we did
and but you know with that money i was
able to pay comedians pretty pretty well
we had some headliners local headliners
but headliners nonetheless that came out
and did the show so we paid them we paid
all the other comedians and
um
that was my first taste in in doing the
comedy production and then i took a
little bit of a hiatus and got back into
it again but i stopped doing the comedy
side of it and i was like man you know
what because i got more nervous about
doing the comedy side than i did about
just actually producing the show and how
well it would turn out so i found my
lane and i found my passion for that um
the other thing is like when i paid
comedians i remember the first this girl
that was on there um
for the first show she got she got paid
35 bucks for doing like five or ten
minutes i forgot what it was she was
great i've seen her be on other shows
but she's like brandon this is the first
time i ever got paid for being on the
show i was like you kidding me right i'm
like you've been on a number of shows in
the area and you never got paid she's
like no she's like i get drink tickets
and maybe some chicken rings she's like
but that's about it yeah i was like i'm
like that's kind of up and that
was another reason why i wanted to do
what i do because
get get comedians that pay mo you know
get paid and we still do this to this
day where like i always say i make a lot
of people a lot of money and i'm okay
with that like i'm not the one who's
who's coming home and bankrolling on it
it's it's other people that are making
most of the money and and that's that's
okay because i know in the long run
that's going to all pay off and with
where we're going you know there's
there's going to come a time where you
know that all that stuff's going to add
up and it's just going to it's it's pot
it's positive when you do this it's like
it's adding like social currency you
know the universe i believe the universe
you do good things the universe pays you
back might not be directly from that
person but it's going to come back from
some way shape or form and so so anyway
the the story was that i got back into
production started doing it i actually
set a goal for myself to do it full time
in 2020 um and i had my first big show
lined up with dean del rey on march 7
2020 in austin texas down on 6th street
and sure enough that was a week before
the world shut down so the turnout from
the show was not very good um it was
decent um
dean did a great job everyone that came
had a fantastic it was just a weird
weird time like newspapers we're reading
i remember even dean i i talked to dean
because he's coming back kind of full
circle he's coming back to austin we're
doing another show with him
and he's he's like dude i'll never
forget that show i'm like me either bro
first it was like my first kind of jump
into doing this full-time second it was
like it was during the weirdest time in
the in
my life you know in all honesty and so
but
during the pandemic we started doing uh
you know things shut down and we weren't
able to do live shows anymore but i was
like i still had the
the vision the passion and wanting to do
this full-time
so i actually i did i shut down my
marketing business i had an agency that
i was running for about five years and
there wasn't much going on as far as
marketing during the pandemic anyways so
i was like i'm gonna take the money i've
saved
and some of the money i was able to
accumulate and i'm gonna invest it into
doing this stuff online and so we
started producing shows online shows not
stand-up shows but like
comedy kind of like we had a variety
show we had a
meme kind of bass show we had we had a
podcast type style stuff so we we tried
everything at one point we had about 10
shows running at um
during the week and
all online no like zoom stand up and and
it was an outlet for comedians to be
able to
um do their comedy have fun you know
interact with other comedians very
similar to what you're doing here with
this and then also it was another outlet
for other people to get you know good
content get their minds off the
but when things started opening up we
started doing live shows
and that all started taking off we found
a really good partnership with vulcan
in austin texas
and um
then the next thing he knows like i made
some strategic moves that all worked out
in our favor which then landed us some
really big shows and worked with some
really big names
and
now we're here we're doing and we
started there doing we were given one
day per week to do comedy shows and
within
about i think it was like february march
we at that point of march 2021 we were
doing shows almost seven days a week
and and killing it selling it out um we
basically took vulcan and and have
turned it into a comedy club and now we
have some of the biggest names that come
through there we do headliners we have
showcases
um
people know it uh rogan talks about it
all the time on his podcast yeah so it's
been a it's been a really fun experience
seeing all that and how it's transformed
um now where we're going is we want to i
and i've i told you this a little bit
off the podcast but what i didn't know
when we started doing this is how
impactful comedy really is in people's
lives um i mean i knew that laughter
can make a difference and i knew the
saying that laughter is a medicine but i
didn't really know how much and after
doing some research it's like it truly
is a medicine um i mean not just from
research but from like first-hand
experience i know if i'm having a shitty
day i go in to the comedy club i sit
down there i watch a show i leave i feel
a million times better yeah um i've
gotten emails from people um people who
have had a really hard time and i had
one person tell me that you know he if
he didn't wake up the next day he didn't
believe anyone would care and he went to
a comedy show laughed for two hours
came back
changed his life turned into 180 now
he's doing now he's doing comedy himself
too and so he thought he found a passion
and you know we hear people talk about
how they they met at a comedy show where
they went there for their anniversary
you know there there's everything from
you know the the sad parts of life that
comedy can help but also like how it
enhances the the happy parts of your
life too um i've seen families bond
bringing kids to see their famous uh
favorite comedians uh we just had uh we
just had vic
the bepto i can't pronounce his last
name but um he uh vic came by and he was
talking with uh this autistic
uh kid who was about 18 years old and
the mom reached out to us and asked if
it was okay to come in there
we don't normally allow 18 plus it's
typically the venue is more like 21 but
we made an exception and so he came in
and got to meet him and it changed his
life like she sent us an email she's
like you know what that was the most
amazing thing in the world they got to
take a picture like an autistic kid i
can't imagine being autistic and going
through that stuff but being able to
find something that you love finding
someone that makes you laugh
that that changes people's life you know
and that's that's the thing is like this
is where we're going like i see how much
it impacts people then i'm like what if
this world
just laughed more if we laughed more
what could we do
you know laughter is proven to create
more positivity in a positive mindset
with positive mindset creates more
productivity better relationships we all
could use that a lot more we make better
decisions when we're more positive and
so with all that said imagine a world
where people are more positive laughed
more um what this could be because i
honestly i think we we used to be that
way
and then we started getting so indulged
with you know social media and online
and all that stuff is good but it really
does mess with your head and so
we've gone to the point where you know
people mental health is
at a crisis you know and and it's at a
height of where it's it's a it's a
problem
so
big laugh comedy is really about making
the world laugh in order to and then and
and also by empowering comedians so we i
always look at it we have two audiences
we have comedy fans and we have com
comedians both of those are our
customers
and with that instead
um
yeah it's like big comics weird just
like weed
i love i love how these are popping
through
but you know like our goal is our goal
is to make the world laugh and and by
doing that we want to um help you know
further people's careers i i heard a
story on rogan talked about this i think
it was on the flagrant 2 podcast or the
flagrant right it's not flagrant 2
anymore but um he was talking about how
he he started when he started doing open
mics he he knew this woman and i think
he was dating her at the time too
and she was he's like she was
hilarious she's like he was like she was
funnier than me and then but she never
made it and never got through it and
he's like i don't know what happened
he's like i stopped you know staying in
touch with her
oh brandon froze
did he freeze for everyone or was that
just me
brandon
he'll be back
we'll give him a minute to reset that is
the perfect freeze frame of his face
though
[Laughter]
everyone says ricky okay cool
hilarious big facts big o
frozen out here everyone yeah i agreed
jeanette
jeanette said comedy is life-changing i
watch comedy every day sometimes i watch
my favorite stand-up over and over i
love clean comedy too
nice
i agree
yeah i totally agree
my q a is too cool said ryan how funny
nice yeah and i appreciate y'all's
questions um
we'll get to as many as we can but i did
want to get to brandon's
like the fundraiser they're doing and
kind of the vision for that because i
think it's super interesting and unique
that i think we can all learn from
just as comedians in general
but um
i did see
dc had a question about storytelling so
i i will um i could do a quick answer on
that one because i want to keep
brandon's questions more towards like
the business and production and things
like that um so if we don't get to your
question
um we will for sure
there he is
and it's all right this is the hotel
this mcdonald's internet sorry no you're
good no you're good no worries ryan said
this q a is too cool
and that's why you froze
awesome
well i i don't know i i know i was i got
cut off in the middle of story but i was
just mentioning how
rogan was talking about this this woman
at the open mics and she was funny as
hell and he's like imagine what she
could have been doing like who knows you
know back then it was a different error
a different day and age
doggy dog world and and and i was like
you know i thought about it i was like
that's exactly why we're doing what
we're doing because
you know what if we could empower people
even at a you know like like jimmy is a
perfect example again not quite there
but um as far as like being up ready for
hosting or feature and maybe he is
um and he's getting close but the the
fact of the matter is that we're giving
him an outlet with the the podcast to do
something and grow and then at the same
time he's able to he comes to the club
he hangs out he watches the comedians he
gets to go up do his thing he's learning
through that process but then you know
the other thing is we're helping them
from the business perspective how to
monetize
their their channels if they're getting
audiences and they're growing and they
got a good product and people are
enjoying it how do you how do you make
some money off of it how do you monetize
it and so by able and imagine like if
that girl who was doing comedy back then
was given more opportunities was also
given an outlet to be able to make some
money while doing something that she
loves to do and nurture that process
imagine where she would be at this you
know now and so that's the thing is like
we want to help all comedians um grow
and empower them and be an advocate for
them um and
and that's and that's really what it
comes down to then and in the flip side
you know more people get to see really
good comedians they also get to meet new
ones like one of my favorite things to
do is not just the large showcases but
like bringing in
like lower name comedians maybe
comedians are just not as well known but
they're really funny bringing them to
the club having them play and then
people walking around but like i've
never heard of this person but i'm a
huge fan and i can't tell you how many
times that happens and it's fantastic
it's so it's so great like helping them
build up their fan base like we've done
it now with a few comedians like paul
versus a great example oh yeah we just
had him on the show yeah yeah paul's
paul's great he just drops his new
special on netflix if you guys haven't
watched it is fantastic really one of
the best podcasts or specials i've seen
in a long time um
and there's been a lot of great ones
coming out so that's like saying
something but paul was
paul
has a great story i got put in touch
with him through emilio who owns the new
york comedy club or one of the owners of
the new york comedy club here in new
york and um he's a great guy too big
advocate in the in the comedy scene um
huge player helps a lot of people he um
and he he shares the same kind of
mentality that's why we click we're like
friends but he put me in touch with paul
about a year and a half ago when we
first started we put a show together we
booked it out paul told me all about
himself um didn't have the biggest
following in the world but really really
fun to do came out he sold 400 tickets
and i was like hey let's do it again we
booked we put another date on the on the
books for a year later
he he thought at the time that his
special was going to drop then so it was
going to help with ticket sales but he
still ended up we still saw end up
selling i think a little over 500 maybe
close to like 5 15 tickets so he did go
do an increase from what he was from the
first time to the second time wow and
then now
you know hopefully he's not going to get
too big from this netflix that he won't
forget the little people
[Laughter]
the little people doing shows with like
joe rogan you mean is that what you're
talking about yeah yeah yeah you know
but still like
um
you know
straight flex you know a little
something just a little sauce on them
um but you know he um
and so i just hope he comes back because
then we can do another show and then
that's that's
um but he he uh so but he's he and
people like that and then like eric
newman's another guy ali makovsky is one
of my favorite comedians um i remember
listening to ali when i first started
doing comedy i started listening to kill
tony on the regular
and um
she she was one of my favorites like her
her jokes and her voice and her delivery
everything was just like amazing
and i've gotten to work with her a a
couple times and she she's another one
like she my favorite thing is that we
booked her she came out we booked craig
connett to come out he was our fourth
show when we started doing shows on and
during the pandemic down here in austin
the fourth show was quick on it he's
like hey i'm going to bring allie
mikoski to feature for me uh she's going
to do like 20 minutes i was like perfect
i'm like this is great and then i ended
up talking to ali's agent and booking
her like a month later so we got to use
that as kind of a springboard for her to
come back um but she came up she killed
she was fantastic then fast forward she
came she comes back a month later she
sells out a single show um and then she
gets out there and and and the crowd is
going crazy like they're like
welcome ali makovsky to the stage and
everyone's like wow
and she got off and she was glowing
she's like brandon she's like that was
incredible she's like that was she's
like oh my god and she like was like a
loss for words and it was just great to
see her she came back and did another
show with us and she's like every time
she's like i don't know what it is about
this stage and what about your your
shows and austin she's like but i always
have my best sets when i do this and and
she's just like and she's like she's
very grateful but she's blown up and
she's blowing up and like a guy like
eric newman is another guy who we've got
to work with we did a little texas tour
with them he's not he wasn't selling
like he sold 130 tickets when he did it
with us in vulcan
but he did um he did a weekend show in
doubt in fort worth and we helped with
that and he sold he sold out two shows
now there were 70
70 tickets per show it was a little bit
small over a stage but he still sold out
too and now we're going to bring him
back for a full weekend come here in
2023 to do a full weekend in austin and
he's blown up too it's just it's great
to be a part of this and see that and
work from you know work with people who
are lower levels like we worked we
worked a couple shows now with chris
distefano too great guy fantastic
comedian i've been a huge fan for a long
time and he actually i reached out to
him via instagram like dm beginning when
we started first doing shows and i i
took screenshots of this too just
because like for memory purposes
like we we started talking in december
2020 and we were like oh him and i
worked out a deal right there on
instagram about him coming down to
austin now he started getting busy and
blowing up and and didn't work out but
january of this year we did finally got
a show to do with him and he sold out
and i looked at the numbers that we did
he was like yeah i think i'll be able to
sell this out and and do these numbers i
think we tripled the numbers oh my gosh
yeah
i love hearing that it was crazy dude
it's just crazy to see how like a year
and a half can change
so much and
um and then he came back and did another
show with us sold that out too
but he and he and he's great man he like
he he told me he's like i love working
with you and that's the thing what we
try to do to set that
that tone and be comedian friendly like
take care of them not be an help
them out like whatever they need i
always tell them this is your show
whatever you need from us you just let
us know and
i think taking that approach of putting
the comedian first also kind of sets the
tone and and changes like and
unfortunately like i've heard stories is
like not every club and place and venue
is like that no most clubs a lot of i
won't say most but a lot of clubs do
just kind of like sequester you so like
get stay in the corner until it's your
turn like it's not the most um
yeah but that's why it's inspiring
people like you
like producing opportunities for
comedians but also treating comedians
you know like
like they would like to be treated yeah
that old way
and that old men mindset around comedy
clubs i'm hoping that's starting to
fade out because it's it ain't pretty a
lot of the places
it is and you're right that like you
nailed it in the head it's the old
school kind of mentality and that and
that truly is like what motivates me and
inspires me to and inspires us as a
company because it's not just me i have
a team behind us like i like i said like
any good professional understands that
they can't do this by themselves i
wouldn't be able to grow and get us to
where we are
if it wasn't for a team of people and so
shout out to everybody at big laugh
comedy everybody behind the scenes um
you know even the team over at vulcan
they've done a fantastic job and and we
and we work together to really put their
needs first and that's why i want to
grow big laugh comedy that's why we
crowded we started this equity
crowdsourcing platf um campaign so it's
it's not uh it's not a donation base
it's not kickstarter it's not a
um a gofundme kind of campaign it is
legitimately
run through the sec
uh i have i had to spend about six to
eight months i think it was closer to
eight months uh spent tens of thousands
of dollars to get everything in line had
to go through you know legal teams and
financial reviews and how to get things
passed through to go through the sse and
we're literally
um raising funds through uh
through selling equity people are
getting to own parts of big laugh comedy
they get to be a part of the owner and
reason is too
is that i always had a dream of
putting the business as like a build it
a brand of for people by the people um
because
we like i i always wanted comedians to
be part owners whether they bought into
it or we gave them equity in some in
some capacity like even before we went
down this road that was a conversation
that i've had behind closed doors for a
very long time and um i believe that
when you have skin in the game too like
one of the things we asked ourselves was
that we had some like really big
advocates for who we are people go out
and they talk about us and love us and
all that stuff but like how do we
convert more average joe fans into more
advocates
and i was like well what if they had
some skin in the game and so we offer
them an opportunity you know in exchange
for
for their money where they're gonna
invest and
like i said we made a lot of people a
lot of money so why stop now
and that's the same concept you know
have them be a part of it
have them become advocates have them
have a voice and feedback in what we're
doing
um at the same time they'll make money
from it too and so when we all benefit
you know when when we make money
everyone else benefits too and so that's
really what it comes down to it's it's
regulated by the the government it was
uh equity crowdsourcing for a lot of
people who don't know
it is through the jobs act that was
created back in 2016 which allowed more
small businesses to get funding um
because really the only way before that
was like vc money or angel investors
or family and friends and all those
outlets are really hard to do so what
they with creating uh the jobs act they
actually allowed they created the start
of the equity crowdfunding platforms um
start engine is one of them it's one of
the larger ones
and that's the one we decided to go with
but we did a lot of research into seeing
what we did
and i even had
people
and i still do i have people who want to
individually invest and which is fine we
take that money but
um this was something that i still
wanted to go down this road because i
wanted to create a
a movement i wanted people to be a part
of it i mean there's a lot of places
that cannot do this because they've
either are established and they're
making too much money and so like why
would i sell part of my business but
we're in a perfect position where we're
young enough we have a proven model and
we have big plans in what we want to do
and how we want to change the world and
i know it sounds corny and cliche but
it's true um
and how we want to help the
the the world people and comedians and
so
you know for you know you can invest for
as little as 150 bucks that's all you
have to put into so what does that look
like like if let's say i i go and invest
like what
what um
what what now
so uh so what happens is that the money
gets donated we have a campaign that
runs about three three to six months
depending um it could be even sooner if
we hit our goal our goal right now is uh
1.07 million dollars and then with that
funds we have what we're actually going
to do is start to
invest and we've already done that we i
mean we we've been investing in in
comedians in the business for
since we started but um we're gonna you
know build out a podcast network we're
going to um create opportunities for
comedians like i said
uh we're gonna
uh we're gonna actually open up our own
venues too we have a couple of places
that we already have in mind um and and
leases that we're ready to go and get
ready and rock and roll and um
and and then expand from there and then
we actually uh i know this is the most
not the most popular thing in the world
right now but nfts is is another avenue
that we're we want to take comedy down
um and it's not just because like it's
not jpeg images you know everyone kind
of like jokes around about that but
yeah there's a lot to create like
even people with photography can sell it
as nfts and there's a lot of things that
comedians can do with these nfts even
with like selling tickets and having
those kind of set up so we're we're
pushing innovation technology
um also just creating an experience and
the goal is to create
um
create an avenue where it's it's a full
experience whether you're in person or
you're online so you can go to a venue
have the best time laugh your ass off
come back home the next day you can wake
up and be like hey go check out this
clip from big laugh comedy this is the
guy that we just saw live in person or
watch the sketch that they just did it's
hilarious it's a it's really
like creating an ecosystem where it
encompasses
all aspects and you know the online
offline
um relationship intertwining and putting
it together mixing it together plus
adding in technology and innovation and
this is something that hasn't really
been done in comedy hasn't really been
done in general some people are starting
to do this a little bit um but it's
really pushing the envelope and it's not
necessarily rocket science but it's just
taking a bunch of little different
industries and mixing it into one and
putting it all under one brand and then
allowing people to create opportunities
for themselves
i love that yeah people in the comments
are saying that sounds awesome
jeanette said she will be investing
uh big o said the money gets invested
back in the comedians nice
yeah
yeah yeah that sounds great i mean it's
like we got we just got a we have a
temporary studio right now but we have a
studio that we're about to start
launches in podcast the jim clifford
show is gonna be recorded there we're
gonna we're talking to some other
comedians uh i just blasted out on our
instagram today that we're looking for
comedians with podcasting ideas
um you know we we do actually we have a
written side too we have a publication
side where we we create we have a
editor-in-chief when we create we have
news and then we have satirical stuff on
there too but
it's also news and like reviewing uh
specials talking about what's going on
in the local communities what's going on
in comedy in general
um you know just
come like everything comedy like
everything related to comedy we are
going to be covering and that's because
i love it and i think everybody should
and there's nothing that really covers
comedy like you know uh jim jeffries
right after the oscars i it wasn't even
regarding to the slap
um the slap heard around the world it
was in regards to like the oscars don't
even nominate like comedy specials or
you know comedians in general and like
like comedians i think is it like comedy
is an art is the most
is one of the hardest art forms there is
because like as a painter you could
paint something look at it say it looks
like throw it out you know you and
and you don't have to worry about
somebody rejecting you as an actor you
could sit there and take do 250 takes
until you get that one that goes up on
the screen but anyone who's not watching
who's not part of the process won't know
that you did that many takes and
you sucked that bad that you had to do
it 250 times but as a comedian yeah you
do that in real time with real rejection
and it is not easy and so like that
needs more recognition that that's how i
see it it needs more recognition
and um needs more respect out there so
we get we got plans to to like do our
own awards and have you know a yearly
thing where we nominate people podcasts
and movies and sketches and that's
another thing we want to get into is
like video content but but bigger like
movies too because i think hollywood
first of all hollywood the entertainment
industry puts drama as the number one
genre
because it sells more around the world
because they say drama and action
sell internationally where comedy
doesn't and i think that's um
there's been proven models that there
it's it translates no matter where you
go um i've seen more and more comedians
now that are traveling overseas and um
and it's been working you know and it
works and people are laughing doesn't
matter what the humor is they still get
it they actually say that some of the
jokes work better overseas than they do
here in america and so
it's like why not do that and and like
and the entertainment industry too is
like they've gotten so the the the movie
um the movie studios are so now indulged
in like nostalgia and things that were
blockbusters and they're they're so
worried about that they're not really
take willing to take risks on original
content and there's so much original
content out there i can't i probably i
know i think everybody has a script
right everyone's got a screen
yeah
i i know that half the people i talk to
always say i got something i wrote
something you know and so it's like why
not take a chance on some of this stuff
i mean it can't be like we're gonna
produce everything but it it's like if
you have an idea and it's actually good
let's take a chance on it and see how it
rolls it rolls with dice and if it's
good and it's done well it'll do well i
mean but so that's that's the thing is
we want to kind of take the risk
and and and take those risks because i
don't i mean i'm i'm kind of fearless at
this point it's like we have nothing to
lose
and let's let's just go see what happens
where can people donate
uh if not even donate yeah i don't want
to come off like it is like a
kickstarter i mean it's literally like
you said it's like
it's like equity i just i didn't know
the right way to like frame it
yeah i've been having kind of a hard
time doing that too but it's invest
right i think um yeah
if you want to invest in comedy you want
to invest in big laugh comedy um you can
go to you can go directly to our website
which is big
blcomedy.com forward slash invest you
can also go directly to the source which
is start engine.com
forward slash
uh
big laugh comedy
so big laugh comedy yep start engine.com
forward slash
big laugh comedy
nice okay cool yeah and you guys have
already raised
and it's a 25 million
valuation
yeah
what
just based on the vision and what you
guys want to do
yeah no no that's that's a very good
question because a lot of people
actually asked that um and i had
somebody today who just asked that so
the valuations are really hard to come
across i i know when i first they were
like here give us evaluation i was like
i don't know how to start with
this and the the best way to describe it
is you take in a couple different
factors one are current numbers two
um some things we don't we don't make
all the profits because we are
essentially the production company and
the venue itself um most of the times
we've done it with multiple venues uh
venues typically keep 100 of the food
and liquor and so
um
you know but we do know what they are
making from the food and liquor and then
if we are running our own full-time
venues that's the the money that we'll
we know will accumulate and they've made
some pretty good
money on our events and so
um
it's it's that factor it's what we're
making it's also
uh projections that i've worked with uh
cpas based on real-life data also
markets and competitors too so the the
like the comedy club industry i think of
last in
was like it was valued at 330 million
dollars
um and then we're going to be getting
into podcasting which there's
advertising sponsorships uh and
opportunities in that which
uh it's a 94 billion dollar industry
right now for podcasting um and actually
i don't know if you knew this but uh
comedy is the number one genre in
podcasting it surpassed uh
news it's like 21 to people who listen
to podcasts listen to comedy podcasts
so if you equate that with the the
billions of dollars in there you just do
of the 94 billion dollar market and
you'll see how much comedy makes and
then also um with some of the other
channels that we're going to in other
revenue streams so there's real money to
be made in what we're doing we're also
not relying on just ticket sales and
food and liquor um which is you know
is is my mind a genius way of going
about it because
in this day and age i think one thing
we've learned anything from the pandemic
is that when you rely on one source of
income you're
you you're right amen to that amen to
that
yep no moss
yeah so i mean even the like the
smartest investors in the world warren
buffett you know has always said don't
put all your eggs in one basket yeah
yeah gotta diversify yep so so that's
what it is man so that's the valuation
that's where that came from
yeah and i just put a link to it in the
live chat and i will put a link to it in
the show notes
of um
of this podcast as well and um
oh yeah ryan skrilla he has a podcast
where he interviews comedians
uh while they're out at restaurants and
he keeps saying cough cough i know a guy
with a good interview show
uh i guess he's pitching his podcast is
there a place right now for people to
pitch
ideas or
yeah you can uh two things you can
either just dr uh dm us on instagram our
instagram handle is at big laugh comedy
um or you could send a direct email to
uh info
blcomedy.com
perfect
awesome well i mean brandon i feel like
there's so much just synergy here and
honestly like anything we can do to help
um or collaborate on you know i think
there's a lot of a lot of similar vision
and just intention and spirit around
what we're both trying to do here so
really yeah anything um anything we can
do together i think it only just helps
so yeah man i i agree 100 agree i think
this your podcast is fantastic
i'll say it again i think this is
definitely something that a lot of
people could use
and i'm glad you're getting the
recognition that you're getting at this
point but
anything you need to from me you let me
know brother like i appreciate you
putting me on here um and thank
everybody for coming on and listening
and spending the time with us
um i'm very grateful for this i don't
take anything for granted and um you are
the man dude so appreciate you
bow down
boom
and thank you evan for hanging out on
this live chat uh we'll let brandon get
back to uh his trip here in new york but
we appreciate everyone for hanging out
with us and uh some comedy tonight
go get them thank you
yeah new york's probably one of the best
pot places for comedy if you guys have
not been to new york city and seen
comedy you are missing 100 yeah i'm
going up there tomorrow for the louis ck
movie premiere
oh sweet they're doing it at the beacon
so i'm making a trip up just for the day
i'll come back friday morning but i'm
going up tomorrow to go to that
oh hit me up i'll be i'll be here
tomorrow maybe we can meet up in person
i'm going to be with the family but
yeah we're doing a hot breath hangout
tomorrow for lunch we're all going to
meet up i think at joda rosa's sandwich
place
okay so uh yeah i'll i'll i'll send you
my uh email or my my uh number and on my
email what the my number you yeah
text me and like let me know where it's
at and i'll try to stop by sounds fun
yeah well thanks for hanging out hop
breath the verse go subscribe to our
youtube channel to participate in these
weekly q as we do and we will see y'all
next week
cool
bye y'all